do people still freak out like my thing
is like everybody comes up and yells
Kelly Clarkson to people if this is your
Hamilton so it's like do people always
come up to you and are just like talking
on stuff about Hamilton cuz it was such
a movement I feel like when I was a kid
and rent came out how popular that was
now blew up that's why Hamilton is for
this generation it's just like enormous
it was that and it no it was weird you
know dahveed used to say this thing this
I love the double you used to say right
outside the stage door you were a Beatle
for a block you don't I mean like once
you cross the 8th Avenue it kind of died
down but it took it took time to get
used to getting recognized at the
airport and stuff like that I was I'd be
looking behind me like who were they
looking at yeah but it was you know a
huge phenomenon changed our lives yeah
yeah yeah but it also gave just really
talented people a chance an opportunity
to really showcase all that you were
capable of like how he wrote those songs
I mean my husband is a full-on cowboy
like raises cattle rode bulls like that
kind of guy tears we went to New York
and he was like he was looking around
going no but looking at me right like it
was like he was like crying like it was
it was so good just such a great moment
in time but I'm so glad that you have
the music now that you're doing yes I
love the year transitioning I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this